[Musique]
bienvenue pour vyp le magazine qui
s'intéresse à celles et ceux qui font
l'actualité dans le département des
zveline émission vous pouvez suivre en
direct ou en replay sur tv78.com et
également en podcast sur de nombreuses
plateformes aujourd'hui je reçois
Sébastien Onomo bonjour bonjour
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
producteur de cinéma de télévision vous
êtes arrivé vous aviez 10 ans avec votre
famille c'était au clés sousbois en 96
ensuite vous avez déménagé du côté de de
villepre en 2004 et vous vivez
aujourd'hui à Plaisir plusieurs œuvres
remarquables que vous avez déjà produite
Funan qui a été lauréa au festival du
film d'cy si je me trompe pas ou encore
la série document terre African empires
vous explorez des histoires fascinantes
d'avant la colonisation africaine ça a
été diffusé sur TV5 Monde et ce le sera
bientôt sur Canal plus Afrique et puis
vous êtes aussi comme on dit dans la
short list pour les Césars catégorie
court-métrage d'animation avec la forêt
de Mademoiselle Tang voilà pour les les
quelques œuvres on va parler de de tout
ça forcément de votre parcours de votre
regard sur le 7ar tout d'abord peut-être
un mot sur ce ce courtmétrage la forêt
de Mademoiselle Tang c'est entièrement
en dialecte du sud de la Chine
l'histoire d'une famille sur six
générations il y a un message fort qui
est véhiculé à travers ce cette
réalisation oui c'est un c'est un projet
qui était très ambitieux de par son
format parce que c'est un c'est un film
de 40 minutes euh donc ce qui est pas
usuel pour un pour un courtmétrage mais
c'est vrai que j'avais une une relation
préexistante avec le réalisateur j'avait
produit son premier long-métrage funane
et quand il est venu me voir en me
proposant ce ce projet je lui ai dit que
au départ j'étais pas super chaud pour
être honnête parce que je sais pas trop
faire pour ce qui estit des des format
cours mais la logique la politique dans
la société c'est d'être dans
l'accompagnement des talents finalement
quel que soit leur leur message et et
leur format et pour Denis c'est un film
qui était important parce que ça fait
partie de son histoire une histoire
familiale qui a commencé il y a très
longtemps en Chine et qui s'est
poursuivi au Cambodge et et qui se pour
suis aujourd'hui en France et il avait à
cœur de faire ce ce film dans ce
dialecte donc le
teou qui est un
dialecte chinois et parlé aujourd'hui
par une communauté chinoise qui a
immigré au au Cambodge et c'est un peu
un un film de patrimoine finalement
puisque c'est il y a très peu de gens
aujourd'hui qui parlent ce dialect dans
le monde et et l'idée c'était de d'en
garder une trace à travers un film et
donc c'est l'exercice auquel on s'est
prêté avec ce ce film et qui aujourd'hui
nous permet effectivement d'être
shortlisté pour pour les Césars et vous
serez fixé fin janvier sur la
participation ou non dans la catégorie
prométrage d'animation on souhaite d'y
être bien évidemment de de le remporter
c'est une production je voulais
commencer par ça parce que ça illustre
effectivement bien la ligne directrice
de votre société euh il y a plusieurs
studios de production au sein de votre
société un saut medéia invest et ensuite
il y a les les sociétés de production
mais la la philosophie c'est de mettre
en avant les talents émergents ça c'est
de s'intéresser à une
multiculturelle ambitieuse autour de
l'Afrique les Antilles les Caraïbes
aussi principalement pourquoi c'est ces
choix est-ce que c'est lié à votre
histoire ou à un intérêt particulier
mois les deux ouais c'est lié à mon
histoire c'est lié à un intérêt
particulier mon parcours a fait que
pendant 11 ans j'ai travaillé dans une
société où j'ai pu exprimer ma ma
curiosité en tant que en tant que
producteur et puis quand j'ai décidé de
me lancer dans dans je dirais
l'évolution de ma propre société là je
voulais que les programmes les films
ressemblent à l'expression de ma
personnalité en tant
qu'individu et donc c'est vrai que ce
sont des des territoire des thématiques
qui qui qui font partie de de mon
quotidien depuis que je suis né et et
j'avais à cœur d'offrir une
représentation plus importante à ces
talents euh qui sont pour moi sous
représentés dans dans le paysage
audiovisuel et cinématographique
européen euh et pas uniquement français
par ailleurs et et et du coup je me
disais que euh là où moi je pourrais
être utile en tant que producteur en
tout cas c'est dans le fait de
d'accompagner ces talents là parce que
les autres films il y a de super
producteurs qui savent les faire euh et
cela pour moi il y avait un manque et
donc je préférais euh me concentrer sur
ça et est-ce que ça fonctionne comment
vous percevez votre rôle et quel impact
ça a sachant que vous êtes aussi
vice-président du syndicat des des
producteurs indépendantsou euh
aujourd'hui euh voilà quel quel impacte
ça et com comment vous voyez votre votre
rôle justement ce message commence à
infuser ouais ça commence ça commence à
infuser alors ça commençait à infuser
sans mois mais en tout cas euh moi pour
pour moi à l'endroit où je me situe oui
c'est c'est quelque chose d'important de
me lever le matin en me disant que on va
euh se battre entre guillemets pour
faire exister des films et et pour moi
il y a toujours cette nécessité dans
tout ce que je fais d'y mettre du sens
euh et et ça cette ligne éditorielle là
qu'on a au sein de la société c'est ce
qui me permet de mettre du sens dans les
films qu'on accompagne et dans les
auteurs qu'on accompagne et dans la
temporalité dans laquelle on les
accompagne parce que toutes ces
aventures filmiques et
cinématographiques sont des aventures
qui prennent beaucoup beaucoup de temps
h h beaucoup beaucoup d'espace aussi
dans nos vies personnelles et donc euh
comme pour un mariage on a besoin d'être
sûr que ce sont les bonnes personnes les
bons projets pour accorder ce temps et
cet espace dans dans nos vies parce que
un film d'animation c'est 5 6 7 ans euh
concentré sur ce
projet-là un film de fiction c'est 34
ans euh et et dans et dans desvis ça
représente quandême beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de temps et pour la série
African empires qui sera bientôt sur
Canal Afrique donc je rappelle ça
explore l'histoire africaine d'avant la
colonisation donc c'est des histoires
très souvent méconnues comment vous les
avez abordé comment s passé le travail
un petit peu dessus bah ça a été là
aussi une aventure qui a été longue mais
qui qui à la fin humainement et
artistiquement nous a
vraiment
nourri moi j'ai grandi en fait avec un
manque de cesist histoire euh je suis
français d'origine camerounaise mes
parents viennent du Cameroun et et
pendant toute ma
scolarité en France et on en parle
jamais on parle de l'Afrique euh
coloniale mais on ne parle pas de
l'Afrique post-coloniale qui existait du
coup avant ça et et
surtout il y a y a une forme de il y a
une forme de de de discours euh qui veut
que l'Afrique n'a pas d'histoire euh et
et ou ou ou pour reprendre les termes de
d'un ancien président n'est pas
suffisamment rentré dans l'histoire
euh et et en vrai euh ça ne correspond
pas à la à la réalité des faits
euh cette histoire elle est elle est
présente dans notre quotidien mais on ne
le sait pas parce qu'on l'a pas appris
voilà et et moi je l'ai appris
tardivement durant ma scolarité
supérieure euh donc j'ai quand même
attendu d'arriver à l'un l'université
pour avoir connaissance de de de de de
ces histoiresl et je me suis dit quand
même que si j'avais eu accès ou ne
serait-ce que un nuage ou un faisceau de
connaissance de cette histoire en amont
à titre personnel je me serais
probablement construit d'une manière
plus différente où les coups que j'ai pu
prendre auraient été moins forts parce
que j'aurais eu d'autres accroches pour
si je puis dire me défendre euh et donc
quand je produis African empires
aujourd'hui je me dis que d'abord je
trouve que culturellement c'est
intéressant de savoir ce qui s'est passé
avant pas que pour des afrodescendants
mais pour tout le monde d'une part et et
ensuite je me dis que ça peut être utile
pour ceux qui euh ont cette cette
culture là dans leur gène euh de
connaître cette histoire pour que eux
n'ai pas à subir ce que moi ou d'autres
on est subi on a subi durant notre
enfant sur un manque de connaissance de
cette histoire là sans être trop trop
pompeux peut-être mais vous vous sentez
investi aussi en unee certaine manière
d'une mission par rapport à tout ça
quand on voit c'estes quand on voit
souvent les jeunes qui sont perdus
manque de repère parce que manque de
connaissance de leur histoire parce vous
l'avez dit hein collège lycée toute
cette partie là de l'histoire on en
parle jamais quoi je me sens pas investi
d'une mission ça fait un peu prophétique
ou christique je je sais pas mais en
tout cas encore une fois moi je dirais
surtout que ce
que ce que je veux c'est
euh mettre mon temps de
manière à contribution de manière utile
et et à l'endroit où je me trouve
c'est-à-dire forger une culture et des
imaginair à un public euh c'est
l'endroit où moi je me sens le plus
utile dans mon travail au quotidien euh
donc à partir de là euh sans que ce soit
une mission on essaie simplement avec
toute l'équipe de se dire que voilà ce
film ces histoires font sens dans un
espace
culturel médiatique où il y a peu ces
propositionsl et où ell du coup viennent
rencontrer quand même un public euh et
et après on se dit que potentiellement
ceux qui vont euh avoir accès à ces
histoires
euh se coucheront euh nourris
euh d'autres informations et se lèveront
le lendemain avec euh une autre approche
euh peut-être plus complète du monde
même si c'est
infinitimal dans tout le le flot d'image
qu'on a aujourd'hui au quotidien mais au
moins euh on on aura l'impression et en
tout cas c'est les retours qu'on a
d'avoir été utile ne serait-ce que sur
un programme pour permettre à à à une
audience aussi
large que possible bah de de de se
nourrir de ces récits ben cette audience
justement là c'est une diffusion sur
Canal canal Afrique il y a eu TV5 Monde
aussi cette série comme d'autres projets
que vous avez pu produire non pas leur
place sur une antenne plus large un
canal plus classique puisque vous
adresser vous l'z dit pas uniquement
aucendant quoiou sûr bien sûr bien sûr
bah moi j'aime non en fait j'aime bien
dire
que c'est pas à moi qu' faut poser la
question ouis voilà moi mon travail
c'est de c'est d'identifier ses récits
d'identifier ses porteurs de projets de
faire en sorte de les produire de de la
meilleure manière possi dans les
meilleures conditions possibles et que
et que derrière ce soit la portée
du public tous ces partenaires
évidemment moi je vais les voir après
pourquoi ils ne prennent pas le
programme moi j'ai pas la réponse et et
et je vais vous dire j'ai arrêté de non
je me pose plus la question je préfère
être concentré sur le présent et être
dans l'action ils veulent pas bon ben
c'est pas grave on passe à autre chose
il y a des partenaires que ça intéresse
ils mettent moins de moyens mais ils ont
envie bah autant faire les choses avec
des gens qui ont envie plutôt que de les
faire avec des gens qui ont pas envie et
qui vous donneront pas les moyens et qui
derrière par ailleurs vous diront ben
regardez c'était pas si bien que ça euh
là on a fait avec des gens qui ont envie
et et et c'est ce qui nous drive aussi
au quotidien c'est c'est c'est que c'est
pas toujours évident de produire ces
œuvres mais on les fait avec des gens
qui ont envie et et derrière tout le
monde est est satisfait de ce qui se
passe et et sur African empire ça
dépasse nos nos espérances au regard de
la configuration qu'on av av de voir les
retombées médiatiques et progressivement
économique il y a ce travail que vous
menez sur les différentes civilisations
on a parlé de l'Asie on a parlé de
l'Afrique aussi la culture urbaine aussi
c'est quelque chose qui fait partie de
l'ADN de de votre ADN et de l'ADN de vos
différentes structures de production il
y a eu le documentaire rudy Gobert
numéro 27 qui est actuellement aussi en
replay sur My canal et puis qui a été
diffusé ou qui sera diffusé sur sur
France Télévision aussi ouais était
diffusé sur France Télé qui a en replay
sur France france télé qui est
effectivement aussi disponible sur sur
My canal et alors comment il est né ce
projet sachant que justement l'idée
c'était aussi de plonger dans les
racines de Rudy gober ce joueur de
basket français he pour ceux qui
connaissent pas mais qui qui joue
aujourd'hui en NBA un des piliers de de
la NBA actuel euh comment vous en êtes
venu à raconter son histoire j'ai
rencontré Rudy en 2015 quand il
commençait son parcours en en en NBA
et et on s'est un peu entre guillemets
perdu de vue euh jusqu'à
2000 2020 voilà 2020 on s on s'est
retrouvé euh autour d'un déjeuner euh
pour parler d'un de de faire un projet
de de de film sur son parcours et euh et
et c'est vrai que dans mon métier j'ai
la chance de côtoyer des artistes des
sportif et cetera et encore une fois je
suis toujours à la recherche de mais
qu'est-ce qu'on va raconter qu'est-ce
qu'on va raconter au-delà d'une
dimension entre guillemets qui pourrait
être celle du bling bling qui moi
personnellement ne m'intéresse pas parce
que mon cotidien est dedans et c'est pas
la vraie vie moi ce qui m'intéressait
c'était de découvrir qui était l'homme
derrière le sportif celui que tout le
monde voit euh avec bah tout le face
qu'on peut imaginer de de d'une ligue
comme la NBA h et et durant ce déjeuner
en fait euh bah je je je pose une
question à Rudy qui est à quel moment tu
as su que tu allais devenir ce joueur
NBA extraordinaire que tout le monde
voit euh aujourd'hui et il me répond du
tac au tac le jour où j'ai reçu la
lettre euh de refus pour mon entrée à
l'inep j'ai su que j'allais devenir un
grand joueur de basket
et là je dis bah tu sais quoi le film il
commence là c'est le centre de formation
pour tous ces basketteurs où passer les
Tony Parker et autres mais là lui il a
reçu cette lettre de refus c'est ce
qu'il a motivé en l' motivé et et et à
partir de là je dis mais en fait c'est
ça le film c'est ça qu'on doit raconter
c'est comment en
fait tu tu reçois cette lettre et et et
et personne ne croit en toi à ce
moment-là mais toi tu as une une
confiance euh tellement exceptionnelle
en tes capacités que tu te dis ok je
vais montrer à tout le monde que qu'ils
se sont trompés hmm et finalement je
pense que c'est un miroir de ce que moi
j'ai vécu dans mon parcours aussi euh où
on m'a toujours dit euh dans dans mes
débuts tu tu ne pourras pas faire de
cinéma parce que je venais pas d'un
monde euh familial euh social euh où le
cinéma était quelque chose
d'envisageable h euh mais j'avais
tellement cette cette envie de
travailler dans cette industrie que je
me suis dit bah ok je vais vous montrer
que euh je peux
et et c'est ça que j'ai trouvé
intéressant dans mes échanges avec avec
Rudy c'était que évidemment toute
proportion gardé
euh mais en tout cas il y avait cette
motivation
qui me semble être intéressante pour
toute une jeunesse de montrer
que en tout
cas si on se donne les moyens et qu'on
travaille on peut se rapprocher de ces
objectifs ou sans découvrir des nouveaux
ou réussir à des endroits où on
n'imaginait pas que c'était possible
parce que on se laisse
pas je dirais entraîné par un
déterminisme social ou sociétal a vous
écouter dans dans dans les projets que
vous défendez que vous produisez que ce
soit Rudy goobbert que ce soit le le le
courtmétrage animé sur sur l'Asie dont
on parlait cette histoire de génération
c'est toujours des histoires de combat
vous vous retrouvez dans chacun des
projets en fait cette histoir de combat
de se prouver des choses à soi-même de
revenir sur la civilisation africaine
qui existait avant le colonialisme et
qui était riche je dirais que c'est des
histoires de transmission c'est des
histoires de transmission euh d'un
patrimoine c'est des histoires d' de
transmission de valeur c'est des
histoires de de transmission parce que
d'une manière presque égoïste finalement
euh depuis que depuis que je suis père
euh tonton bah je me dis que j'aimerais
que mes enfants mes niè neveux
euh ne grandissent pas avec ce manque
que moi j'ai eu quand j'étais plus jeune
et par extension j'imagine que d'autres
l'ont eu aussi euh et que du coup les
films qu'on produit les personnalités
qu'on met en avant les artistes qu'on
accompagne sont des gens qui sont
inspirants pour ces nouvelles
générations et j'ai l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui dans le monde dans lequel
on vit nos jeunes ont besoin d'être
inspirés par des gens qui ont des des
parcours positifs euh et qui cherch à
transmettre cette positivité pour que
euh il soit moins perdu voilà et vous
avez l'impression que ça évolue
favorablement au sein du cinéma on
reproche beaucoup à l'industrie du
cinéma toutes les productions qui
peuvent sortir séries télé autres euh
cette espèce de de wokisme de on efface
tout on on ni toutes les histoires qui
ont pu se passer on ne cherche plus à
comprendre ce M multiculturalisme que
vous vous défendez ces histoires ces
personnages que vous défendez vous avez
l'impression que vous êtes pas le seul à
le faire quoi non j'ai j'ai j'ai je
pense que il y en a d'autres qui le font
je pense qu'on est peu parce que parce
que c'est un c'est un vrai choix c'est
un vrai partiprix de de consacrer une
ligne éditoriale à à ses sujets à ses
personnages à ses
personnalités mais encore une fois je le
fais moi à titre perso sans trop me
poser de question parce que pour moi ça
fait sens euh après c'est vrai qu'on on
est dans une industrie qui a tendance à
à se regarder un peu le nombril euh et
et je dis ça je peux m'inclure dedans
aussi à certains moments hein parce que
on on est tous
euh voilà la la la tête la tête un peu
dans dans le guidon et et pas forcément
toujours connecté au aux réalités du du
monde mais 2023 a été assez rude h euh
sur le fait de nous rappeler que il y a
un certain nombre de réalités et que
bah c'est bien de de de de de raconter
ces histoires pour que les gens dans ces
dans dans ce qui se passe autour du
monde et davantage de clés de
compréhension voilà et et nous quand
quand on fait tout ce qu'on a pu faire
on imagine que ça peut donner des clés
de compréhension
supplémentaires à ce qui se passe dans
le monde euh sur certains
conflits
euh certaines euh certaines histoire
aussi qui se qui se passe en France et
cetera et et de dire euh
bah comprenez euh de manière plus large
quelle a été l'histoire de manière à
aussi peut-être ne pas répéter les mêmes
erreurs h on va parler d'histoire encore
pendant les les 5 minutes qui nous reste
pour cette émission avec vous Sébastien
Nomo sur votre métier de de producteur
et votre histoire votre prochain projet
euh qui est en cours de montage hein qui
a déjà été tourné euh c'est une figure
de l'anticolonialisme que vous mettez à
à l'honneur c'est France Fanon
philosophe écrivain né à fort- de-
France il s'est impliqué notamment dans
la lutte pour l'indépendance de
l'Algérie il a analysé la
dépersonnalisation entraînée par la
colonisation aussi on y revient il s'est
battu contre le racisme ça va de soi euh
il a aussi admiré par Sartre il a des
liens avec Sartre aussi pas mal euh
c'est tous ces aspects-là que vous allez
mettre en lumière quelle est la ligne
directrice de de cette histoire à venir
oui c'est ça c'est on a choisi on a
choisi la période algérienne de de de ce
personnage c'està- dire le moment où il
arrive en Algérie avec sa avec sa femme
pour diriger l'hôpital de Blida et où
finalement vont vont
euh se rencontrer euh je dirais sa son
son approche théorique euh de
de son de son travail de de de penseur
entre le rapport entre colon et et et et
colonisé
et un peuple celui d'Algérie qui veut
recouvrir sa totale
indépendance et et
là ce personnage cette figure se dit que
c'est en Algérie que je pourrais de
manière concrète app appliquer euh
ou mettre en
lumière ce que j'ai théorisé jusqu'à
présent entre le colon et le colonisé et
donc nous on on fait un focus sur cette
période qui nous semblait être la plus
parlante de de son parcours d'éto
d'étoil filante parce que c'est c'est
quelqu'un qui est mort à 36 37 ans d'une
d'une leucémie foudroyante et
qui en l'espace d'une vie très courte
aura laissé un leg fondamental dans la
compréhension d'événements qui se
passent notamment aujourd'hui mais là
aussi on est sur une histoire qu'on
apprend pas au collège qu'on apprend pas
au lycée qu'on apprend pas à l'école au
plus jeune ouais ouais ouais et c'est
encore une fois une des raisons pour
lesquelles moi je considère finalement
qu'on crée des outils h filmiques
cinématographiques qui sont euh
euh des ponts euh culturels pédagogiques
que pourront utiliser des enseignants
pour raconter cette histoire de manière
différente euh au jeunes public euh ou
au public tout court euh parce que
encore une fois nous on ne les a pas eu
quand on était plus jeune et et
peut-être que si on les avait eu ça nous
permettrait aujourd'hui de mieux
appréhender euh les événements euh qu'on
vit aujourd'hui colc tivement et qui
sont pour beaucoup juste des répétitions
de l'histoire passée h merci beaucoup
Sébastien r vous êtreevenu sur ce
plateau parler de votre studio de
production mais on l'a bien compris
parler de plus que ça de beaucoup plus
que ça on espère que ça vous a inspiré
aussi enrichi émission que vous pouvez
réécouter en podcast voir en replay sur
notre site internet également vyp
revient très bientôt et puis on vous
invite je vous invite à découvrir toutes
les productions de Sébastien Onomo il y
a le le nom du studio Production qui
s'affiche pour ceux qui nous suivent à
la télé en dessous en bas de votre écran
merci beaucoup merci Sébastien merci
[Musique]
wifri